My Korean friend is getting married soon.
It took like a century for her to find the right guy,..
...but the funny thing is, she had been going out with this guy for like what, over 3 years,...
...but ended up marrying another guy, who is super rich.
I don't understand why she wouldn't marry the first guy because they seemed to love each other.
You know what, maybe it's a whole different story:...
...a romantic relationship and marriage.
Hmm, I think most couples marry for love,...
...but it sounds like some consider money, career or fame to be more important,...
...which is not a completely ignorable factor.
Let's see, when two people get married, they can't just live forever with only love.
If they want to have a "happily-ever-after" life,...
...to a certain extent, they should be financially stable.
In Korea, we have matchmaking firms that list all your education history, family history, personal data and career...
...with your income range attached to it so customers can meet the right person according to the data.
But still, the most important thing is love.
Can you guarantee that two people who meet through the matchmakers will feel eternal love?
Well, they might, but I doubt it.
I guess the trend for couples in Korea is to regard environmental factors as more important.
For example: family history, overseas experience, et cetera.
Those nurturing factors are considered to be one of the crucial factors in marriage.